[Music]
first of all hi I knew you so many
changes so tell me what a solo sound of
you is cooking up to be I'm excited you
know it's its discovery from myself you
know there's so many people that are
excited for me trying to see Oh what is
she gonna do next
what is your money sound like I'm still
trying to figure that out I'm in the
studio and it's it's really cool because
I talk about things that I actually want
to talk about and things that I feel
genuinely and I can finally fully be
myself I feel like you know within the
group and I'm so so grateful for the
process but I can speak for all of us
you've only been able to see a fraction
of who we are individually so I'm
excited how was it making that
announcement to the fans like
heartbreaking scary very scary and
heartbreak for me personally like the
first day that we even put out the
announcement for the high hagas it was
the toughest day so many people saying
oh my god what happened like what's
wrong and just having that attention on
something that you already know is real
and the fact that everybody else knows
it's real it's like wow this is really
happening and it's definitely gonna be
an adjustment it's all I've known for
the last six years but I'm excited was
there something like is there a drama we
don't know about that cause this breakup
like do you wanna clear the air is it I
have no air no air to clear but no
there's no air clear it's an
understanding that we have amongst each
other it's it's literally been six years
you know and I feel like we we owe that
to each other and we owe it to ourselves
to figure out Who am I now far down the
road like 15 20 years from now would you
guys gets together again and do
something big in the future I'm all in
I'm in
[Music]